hey guys welcome back to the Spates
watered podcast here we are it is the
dance and France final preview show two
of the most dominant teams in the
history of the sports face off on the
biggest stage it is the perfect way to
finish what has been an incredible Rugby
World Cup and if you are watching this
on YouTube no I have not had a stroke
I'm straight back from the dentist so
excuse the sloppy face but um before we
look ahead we have to look back to the
weekend which has just happened it
didn't quite live up to the
quarterfinals which we had the week
before where um we had four of the most
incredible games of footy but it still
did have plenty of drama um that we
always get from this great game and
again we are lucky to be joined by two
of the great rugby analysis in the game
two of the best of the in the world
we've got sirle from sirle talk Sport
and Jacob the snob Atkins who Jacob you
look like you've had about a thousand
Spates over there mate what's going on
yeah I'm back in London Jim I flew back
to be with my my country men and women
after
after last weekend's uh emotionally
draining performance shall we say now
I'm back in London few Quiet Ones this
this evening and looking forward to
chatting with you Lads across the globe
M how have the country handled it I'm a
couple episodes into this David Beckham
docko and I can't believe um some of the
abuse those the public and the media
give their their National
side uh yeah do you know what I think
it's actually been received pretty well
but my old man and my younger brother
were at the game and my dad came to pick
me up from the airport when I when I
came back into London uh on Monday and I
was expecting him straight away to just
be like oh it's a disgrace we
should have won blah but I think the
actual basically the opinion has been
that regardless of what the result was
we weren't going to win this World Cup
right if we'd got over the line against
South Africa I think everyone was well
aware that unless it was blowing a Gil
force and pissing down sideways rain we
weren't going to beat the All Blacks
next week as well um so making the final
wasn't really the be all and end all
people were just happy that there was a
performance put out that everyone could
see to kind of get claw some respect
back and kind of maybe silence some of
the people that have said oh you don't
deserve to be there like you can say
what you want and England did have an
easy draw Etc and it has been a pretty
pretty cushy World Cup for England and
Argentina but England showed at the
weekend that they are a team
that if a few things were done
differently maybe could be a serious
semi-final team whereas Argentina I
think didn't show that at all so I think
generally the the opinion over here has
been people have been pretty happy of it
pretty proud of the lads like and just
um you not too focused on the result
more focused on like we thought we were
going to have 25 30 but us so to go down
by a late kick I think everyone's just
seeing it for what it is pretty calm
heads we weren't expected to win this
world cup anyway you know fair enough
because yeah massive shout out to
England for the effort they put in like
they were they looked in control of that
game for a majority of it so um yeah I
think they can leave that World Cup with
their heads out hiide and um obviously
go looking forward to this weekend
though um all blacks are at the big
dance Surly you called this from the
start you said sir Ann Foster would be
knighted at the end of this Rugby World
Cup you obviously thought France would
be here but um South Africa um M you're
the Oracle you've always called these um
these performances from a long way out
yeah I guess that that one point loss
from France probably tripped up the
ultimate production there and I probably
would have gone viral you know I'd
probably be on sports right now speaking
about how I can just see the future but
hey it it is what it is and like you
said in the intro I think the southern
hemisphere fans anyway get the final
that we were after right I thought like
full credit to England and like they had
a game plan that a lot of people don't
like especially over this side of the
world but they dragged South Africa into
a ship fight which was the plan going in
and they almost pulled it off and man it
reminded me of like that 2019 semi in a
way where all of a sudden England could
have won that game and you just be like
what did I just watch but full credit to
them like they were so close to pulling
it off so yeah much like what snaky said
like I took my hat off to England I
think making the semi for them was a big
win um but I do think we got the final
that we're after yeah 100% looking
forward to this week it's going to be
huge but we will talk about that all
black Argentina game obviously um 30
points was sort of predicted by majority
of us it was in fact 38 446 was the
final score what' you make of the game
early in a hole Yeah I think as New
Zealand fans or like the public have
been a bit harsh this week like I see
people being like Oh that was a
semifinal and no you can't win because
the or blacks were played unreal like
yeah Argentina probably weren't
semi-final worthy and that Island game
was obviously probably more deserved to
be the semi-final and watching the game
I felt sorry for Ireland right like
they're back at home watching that one
just being like man we could have made
history and and made a semi-final and
made much more of a contest of this but
at the same time you got to tip your hat
to the All Blacks like they were playing
so fast there's so many times there
where they get to fourth or fifth phase
and like Aaron Smith or like the rut
cleaners aren't even there because
they're just so far ahead of themselves
like they were truly dominant I thought
Argentina in the first 10 minutes played
with a lot of passion a lot of Pride
they certainly don't muck around at the
contact areas so I'm sure they would
have still been some sore bodies but
they reminded me so much of rugby league
and like we know with David Kidwell
there but they were carrying winding up
from about 10 m behind the advantage
line steaming in and then like seventh
or eighth phase once they got into our
Red Zone they just put through like a
pointless little grubber like it was the
last tle and they were forced to do that
so I was a bit confused by it as well
but yeah obviously the All Blacks ticked
every box that was needed I think we
said last week like the ultimate result
would be for 50 minutes the game's done
you can pull off some bodies get a bit
of rest in well we finished the game
with 14 A lot's been made of that but it
was the final 3 minutes like people
saying that's an move of arrogance like
pull your head in but yeah I think it
was literally the perfect outcome for us
I don't think we saw the same mental
intensity from the All Blacks but that's
only natural and in saying that like I
mentioned in the buildup to the island
game you could tell the boys were locked
in you get that exact same feeling this
week like we saw Dalton in the press
conference yesterday saying the lads
were shedding tears at a team night
about the stories of how much the Jersey
means to them and the leadership group
around their last World Cup and stuff
like I have a feeling man there's an
onslaught coming but I'm sure we'll get
to that soon but yeah impressive and
then will Jordan should have had four
Richie Mo show and go the trademark
probably the worst time to pull it out
as first fives ourselves though I I
don't know about you guys 100% would
have done the same thing and tried to
dot down for a famous famous meeting but
will makes history right like he or he
ties history he's about to become
hopefully this week the most prolific TR
scorer in World Cup history so yeah it
kind of ticked every box didn't it in a
quick summary yeah mate what quick
summary mate you've nailed everything
but you're right will Jordan I was
probably one of the few who was actually
quite happy Richie Mo went the show and
go because like triple Captain Mark
tiller and and will Jordan was actually
on fire in that game I should never have
doubted the man's ability to find the
find the white line cuz he is incredible
but you also talked about David Kidwell
and their D and it being quite League
esque it also looked like their Wingers
were defending like that because man
there was some easy space wide like it
was pretty easy often for those Wills
tries um just an easy long ball no one
even in sight like just jamming hard
like they do in League so but really
predictable pictures so um we did sort
of expect Argentina to struggle on the
edge um hence why we predicted the score
but um it was all too easy but one thing
I did really enjoy was the All Blacks
Edge like I know I've had a lot of
questions on that throughout the um
World Cup and the podcast but I was
really liking how hard some of their
backs were coming when they got to
numbers on Jordi Barrett in particular
far out when as soon as they got man on
he was flying out putting all sorts of
pressure on Anton Brown's done it as
well coming coming off the bench as soon
as their numbers on they're really
coming with some heat and putting some
aggressive tackles in which is awesome
to see and jordy's jordy's performance
was incredible in that game um his
intent in some of those collisions and
Carries and his skill set M he is world
class best 12 in the world in my opinion
for sure what' you make of the game
Snake geez we've spoken a long time
without getting to you Bo I tell you
what we need to start planning this show
and talking about what each other are
going to talk about on our notes before
we get because Jimmy I was gonna cue you
up perfectly to say that fuzzy and the
lads have obviously been listening to
the show listening to you moan about the
deal week because I thought I I thought
the exact same thought the edgd looked
way way better this week and that gets
me uh gets me fired up for South Africa
this weekend um I think uh like we said
you both touched on it we predicted that
it would be probably New Zealand in the
area of 30 points but I certainly didn't
predict it would be this easy I was
thinking 30 points in terms of a maybe
the ABS go 10 15 up into the last 20
Argentina have to stick or twist they go
for it and then the ABS run away with it
with the with the better bench strength
the better Fitness levels Etc but Jesus
they were absolutely cruising weren't
they and the the scariest thing for me
was
Argentina started the game well exactly
like surle said they had heaps of
possession they had heaps of territory
they kept the ball for long periods of
time but I never at any point point
thought that they were going to score
and then the All Blacks turned the ball
over penalty penalty kick to the corner
three phases Advantage score in the
corner yeah out of nowhere and that must
absolutely just kill all your morale on
Argentina's side of the ball second try
they go do the exact same thing heaps of
territory heaps of possession I said to
you Lads on the chat they were like a
loaded gun without a Tri like they had
all the territory all the possession and
they just never looked like firing any
shots and then New Zealand turned the
ball over shift shift Rico Yani goes 80
meters three phases and then Jordy
scores in the corner and then your 10
minutes you four four or they kicked the
goal didn't they they miss so you're
basically 10 points down and you've been
the better team with an 80 plus percent
territory in possession and I think that
just showed that like early you're right
like the All Blacks didn't seem to have
the same intensity mental intensity that
they brought to the island game but
almost like
how could they like they
Wen they didn't need to they they had
three possessions in the first 12
minutes and scored three tries basically
if if you're not considering exits as
possessions and that for me was like
that's so impressive Lads like it's
easy to be intense and accurate when
it's a a back and forth game and you're
going at each other but when you don't
see the ball for five minutes so then
just snap into attack shift shift and
execute like a it looked like training
ground stuff Jim it looked like training
shape that you run on a Thursday when
you're just trying to get the confidence
up for the boys and and move them around
and uh I was really really impressed by
this game man I was really really
impressed they made it look easy they
did they definitely did and anyone who's
blaming Angus Gardner for um this result
is absolutely laughable like Argentina
obviously Miss missed 51 tackles in the
game so like that's that's hard to know
whether that's all blacks being
incredibly good at beating Defenders or
putting them under all sorts of pressure
just some really average D so that's
going to be interesting to see how that
goes this weekend against South Africa
who obviously defend a lot heavier but
Mark T shout out to Mark T 14 tackle
breaks that guy got to be the
slipperiest man in the world like some
of those carries like just around the
rock just getting really busy and just
beating five or six um forwards before
setting up a try is just incredible
stuff snakey looked like you want to say
something there yeah mate they basically
Chuck him in as an extra locy in the Red
Zone don't they and run three PODS of
three so they play with him as like a
free number eight like it's absolutely
ridiculous yeah that that that passage
you were talking about was outrageous in
International Rugby against a physical
pack to pick the ball off shoulder off
nine and get through four tackles from a
standing start yeah must have night last
week because he was flying I know they
drag Ted will Jordan after the game but
I reckon they need to get like a skin
sample from Mark TOA because I reckon
he's just baby oiled within an inch of
his life a and that's it's got to be
illegal or like veline or something cuz
n one can get a hold of them they got
the wrong there's no rules there's no
rul on that you can we as much vaseline
as you want it's probably underutilized
more players should do it crazy stuff
but one thing we have got like obviously
there's been a few complaints about the
draw and um how it's all sort of worked
out but what we have got from the finals
football in this Rugby World Cup is
we've had five games out of the six go
right down to the very last play so um
whether it was right or wrong the draw
what we have got is like five Incredibly
Close intense games of footy we haven't
known the winner right until the end
that was the only real blowout of the
finals footy so um whether you say it
was the right draw or not it has given
us a pretty good outcome especially last
week in the quarterfinals that was
incredible and another game which was
right down to the wire which we spoke
about is England ver South Africa um and
what a game we've spoken about a little
bit in the intro but what a game that
was what do you make of it
snake yeah it was a good game certainly
in terms of the the context and the
pressure and stuff um not sure it was a
great one for the neutrals or Lads like
ourselves who love heads up fast code
boys playing the space but hey boys this
was the kind of game my dad
loves but he's a he's he's a 50y old
Englishman who's watched the Premiership
for his whole life so um look I think
from from England's point of view and I
I guess we're going to touch on South
Africa a lot when we we look at the
preview for the final so I'll kind of
have my say on England I think in terms
of the result the and the performance
and I've kind of whenever I've got into
England I've been careful to say the
lads on the field have done a
good job here um and and this is a
really good result and performance in
the context of the whole world cup I
think the lads that went on the field
went out there they did they did
fantastic against a very very good
spring box team and they essentially
beat the spring box the way that the
spring box beat France so
impressive job hats off to everyone
everyone involved on the pitch for
England um I think the tactics were were
very very clear and simple and
incredible
repetitive basically England's game plan
was receive the ball either carry and
set up a contestable box kick or go
straight to a contestable kick send the
Winger after the kick then there's two
decisions if the Winger can get there
and slap the ball back he goes for the
slap back and they've obviously
organized three players to connect in
behind the slapback to um get on any
loose balls from from that contest if
you can't get the slap back land the
Collision hit and Chase and then the
three players going fire that rock as
hard as they can make an absolute
fight of it win the ball back or win a
penalty and then punch a grubber into
the corner and basically make South
Africa try and play out from their own
goal line and keep that on a repeat
until you win a pen kick a goal South
Africa get a knock on Etc um and it was
successful you can't deny it was
successful and look I'm I'm not an idiot
I understand that the conditions played
A massive part in this game um
you know if if this is a a game on at
5:00 on a dry French afternoon does this
game plan work for
England probably not um but tactically
they were perfectly set up and like I
was just flicking through the stats like
England 41 kicks to South Africa's 29 so
you really shows that both teams kick
kick the leather off the thing 11 of
those kicks regathered 961 kick meters
for England so that is like that's an
absolute kick Aon that is re that is
Relentless um commitment to the game
plan but the one that made me laugh was
the the running meters ball in hand so
England 236 running meters ball in hand
South Africa 190 meters ball in hand
right compare that to the other
semi-final Argentina 522 New Zealand 621
so that's a third of the running meters
and you can say oh the All Blacks bashed
Argentina up Argentina is still part of
530 run
meters so the conditions played a part
but this was a a rough game to watch I
think South Africa were really poor they
didn't adjust well they didn't adap well
I think the coaching team were proactive
which is good to see you don't often see
it in rugby like coaches in the first
half being like we're tactically
not set up right for this game we have
to make changes yeah I think it's it's a
brave call and it's a tough call on leok
and and vmsa to pull them off pretty
early but the moment that they sat down
saw the conditions saw how the game was
unfolding I think razi had to get paard
on as quick as possible he had to get
laru on at the back to try and do
something to reorganize the back field
and change the the nature of the game so
they reacted well and ultimately lad's
like yeah they probably deserve to lose
the game on the day England probably did
deserve to go through but sign of great
teams and it you win games that you're
not supposed to win you win games that
you've been outplayed in um and in the
context of the World Cup you can't you
can't argue that South Africa shouldn't
be in this final at all so hats off to
them hats off to Razzy and um I think in
in a strange way is it is impressive to
South Africa can just grind these winds
out isn't it yeah geez good summary
snake and um your swear Count's gone up
massively after a few diesels it's good
to
see but you did mention rassie and and a
subbing and like it's it's such an
interesting one he like it looked like
it was quite emotional at the time when
leok shanked one of his cros kicks he
was the next play immediately subbed off
same with um kis rck when he shanked one
of his box kicks next phase he was
subbed off as well but um obviously with
the conditions that game was always set
up for polard so it's almost like why
didn't they even
swap it before kickoff like and it was
always set up for paard um leok did his
best he kicked his goal he was doing he
was doing all right he wasn't doing
anything too bad other than a couple of
Shanks but the game was always set up
for poad and you've got two contrasting
tens like they do one very attacking one
very sound um it almost makes sense to
for Rassy to go into a game not knowing
which one he's going to pick and um see
what the conditions are going to be and
play the one that's going to suit cuz so
contrasting which you don't often get in
teams you wonder why teams wouldn't do
that more but not often you'd have such
contrasting Styles as you tend cuz you'd
want a consistent sort of style as your
team shape so interesting one though
what do you make of it surle you're
obviously a big scrum expert too so you
would be interested to get your thoughts
on how you felt the scrum change of the
game yeah well like you said I'm the
poor man's Mike cron so um I love a good
scrum and that All Blacks game that was
the most disappointing aspect for me
there was wasn't a scrum for the first
29 minutes you know that's what I park
up on the couch on my mornings to watch
so yeah this this one was definitely an
interesting game for the first 70
minutes she was a pretty tough watch and
to be honest if it wasn't a Rugby World
Cup semi-final I probably would have
turned it off and not watched on from
there but the last 10 minutes was Unreal
just because of the drama and what was
at stake but snaky mentioned before the
kicking I think they England kicked away
93% of their position so whenever they
had the ball that's a great start that
was the go-to option and they spent 72
seconds in South Africa's 22 across the
game and almost won the game so unless
I've been stitched up with those stats
from a pretty reliable source then
that's crazy like the fact you can do
that and lose a game by one point is
almost a credit in itself um you
mentioned leok before if that was me
getting pulled after halftime I'm in the
sheds on the cold ones and you know
either either way I'm having an absolute
day of things I'd be furious throwing
the strap and tape the works but like
you said it's so interesting right like
we saw the Box start against France
great conditions first half what a game
of rugby that was to watch them play
Then in this game completely different
contrast so you do like snaky said and
like what you said Jimmy you got to tip
your head to the spring box their
ability to just adapt to however the
game is being played and still get the
win regardless of the style they have to
play is incredibly impressive I do
wonder if they're starting to fatigue a
little like they had Ireland they had
Scotland they had Tonga who they put
away by 30 points but man there were
some big shots going in there and then
France and England like that's a tough
six weeks on the body and it's been the
same 23 really throughout all of those
games like they have this amazing bench
and stuff but there hasn't been a lot of
movement around the squads whereas the
All Blacks have been able to like
restrict time on legs so much more so do
wonder if that'll play effor this week
but yeah full credit to South Africa it
wasn't n't pretty for a mutual fan um
but at the same time like I said at the
start I'm just glad they got it done I'd
almost be more nervous taking on England
in a final for some reason just because
like I feel like they just drag you into
it and like our kicking game hasn't
always been a bigger strong point
throughout this all black cycle over the
last kind of 18 months so I feel better
knowing that it's South Africa and that
they'll probably try play some footy
with us yeah I'm definitely more nervous
playing South Africa then I would have
been playing I thought if we played
England I thought it could have been a
big score especially on a on a dry night
but South Africa I am relatively nervous
about I think this one's going to go
right down to the W don't get me wrong
I'm nervous I'm nervous I feel like if
we lose to South Africa it'll be we'll
be allowed to play our Styles still
where I feel like if we took on an
England and tried to play Force back
with them we'd just get strangled but
maybe not n fair enough and that is why
you two are the two best analysists in
the game they great rundowns of um two
great semi-finals but one thing that we
haven't really spoken about which was
always a big concern going into this
Rugby World Cup was the high shots and
how many red cards and yellow cards
there was going to be when we got into
the finals footy but there's actually
been hardly any I can't actually
remember one high shot in the
quarterfinals and semi-finals I could be
wrong there there's been a couple of
cards but they've been for slap downs
and few cynical things but nothing High
shot so either full credit to all the
players who have adjusted to the rules
really quickly and no head on shoulder
or maybe the tmo's not been as inclusive
as he was at the start intrusive as he
was at the start so I'm not sure what's
your thoughts on that well it's
interesting like we've had five cards
throughout this tournament um but not a
lot of them have been for high shots
whereas South Africa a team so on for
like aggression and big bodies they've
only had the one throughout the whole
tournament so like teams have been
really well disciplined and I think like
as a result the refs haven't had to
intervene too much it's almost been more
the tmos which is why I don't understand
like why the riffs are cooping it so
much but that's that's a different
subject but I do think like discipline
especially in this final is going to be
massive but it was good to see on the
weekend like clearly there's been talk
about it amongst these teams they've
adjusted and I think the rift have been
quite open in like their dialogue as
well to teams throughout the week around
what they're looking for so I I think
the refering has been good man like
they've only made calls that they've had
to make yeah 100% And speaking of
referees obviously we spoke about it
last week who we thought would be um
given the final and it is of course
Wayne Barnes who in my opinion has been
the best referee for a long time and I
think he's the perfect man for the job
and I think he'll do a great job and
hopefully um gets through the game with
no controversial calls which is
impossible but um stay hopefully the
results sort of conclusive enough that
the referee doesn't come into play
because like we always say if you look
through the eyes of one team there's
probably going to be 30 sort of calls
that could have gone against you so um
if the game's pretty conclusive then no
one will need to be going down those
routes to find every little mistake or
Miss he could have done but we let get
let's get to the final um we've spoken
about it huge game massive and what a
way to finish uh this Rugby World Cup
snaky who are you picking I know at the
start of the year you said France and
Ireland were the two clear dominant
teams in World rugby none of them are in
the final so you're going to have to
make this one up up the South oh lad I
know it's a sad week man just under two
months of World Cup rugby and finally
the last Northern Hemisphere team's gone
this was supposed to be our year boys
this is supposed to be our year in
Europe but same old faces the race for
four championships the two the two old
horses going at it um what do I think
for the final honestly Lads the head
says all blacks the heart says all
blacks but rassie says South Africa
gonna win and you boys know I love
rassie I can't go against him um boys
I'm hoping for an all blacks win you
boys know how bad I want that black
passport um and to be accepted as one of
your own but I just
think maybe this is some kind of
emotional scarring I've not addressed
from the 2019 World Cup final I just
think these South Africa Lads when they
decide that they're doing it for South
Africa and you've got people shouting at
paard as he lining gos up for South
Africa I just I just think there team
set up to win in the big
dance um like I said I really hope the
All Blacks do it I really don't want
South Africa to win but I assumed you
boys were going to go ABS as well so I
was hoping to give you something to
disagree with yeah no I like that and
obviously surle you've been calling all
blacks from the start you never sort of
lost hope even when they lost to France
first round but you obviously haven't
changed here why are the All Blacks
going to win in your opinion yeah I'm
backing the boys to get it done I think
the improvements we've made throughout
this tournament have just been massive
and this is a side now that is hitting
their straps they're playing their best
footy we've got everyone available
healthy ready to go and I just feel like
we're peing at the right time whereas
some of that fatigue and that South
African game might be slipping in
obviously it's a World Cup final so
they're going to be up for it but I
think it's just that like that effect of
being able to rotate the squad have a
slightly easier run in but also really
create this like identity amongst this
team we know what we're going to get
from the or blacks now and that we've
seen it develop throughout this
tournament so yeah I just feel really
confident like I think it all comes down
to the start I think whoever's winning
at like that 20 25 minute Mark will win
this game we've played South Africa
twice this year whoever was winning at
that point went on to win the game we
played them at Mount smart we're up 170
early game over then we played them at
Twickenham got dominated early game over
so I think if we can be ahead of them by
like 10 15 points they're going to have
to play expensive footy then en chance
their arm and I think that falls into
the All Blacks trap I think if it's like
a three-point differential heading into
the last 10 minutes then I'll be really
nervous but I think we've got the
weapons to take them on our set Pieces
come on so far I mentioned that
twickingham game no Jordy no frazelle
then so I think you can cancel that out
cu both of those two make a massive
difference so yeah for me it's all
around the fast start I think kicking
game is going to be huge high ball
diffusal but I trust like toia I trust I
trust Barett and then Richie moang has
been dropping back there and doing an
amazing job and I think our transition
attack off the back of that is
outstanding and I just like what I've
seen from the All Blacks like our set
piece attack off line outs again we saw
them Target that tail of that line out
against Argentina for will Jordan's TR
that chip and Chase like there's and
that came around the same time of that
game they've clearly identified like a
fatigue level around the 60 Minute Mark
to attack that tow I don't see why they
won't do the same against South Africa
there's just so many aspects that are
coming into it for me the one thing I am
worried about is uh kickoff exits I
don't know why but at the moment I
thought they were really patchy on the
weekend and pretty dusty against Ireland
as well we're kind of in that two minds
as to whether to exit straight away or
try get to wh then exit and it can be a
bit chaotic like both times we started
those games as well both nudgers would
have been lucky to go 10 meters like it
was like you were watching 10year olds
again so I don't know I'm sure they've
gone through that and identified it
because Africa will look to Target in
that area as well but yeah like bomb
squad I back our bench against them our
bench is stacked as well so I truly do
think whoever's winning at that 25
minute Mark goes on to win the game so
hopefully it's us mate well the Oracle
has spoken and there you go so if you're
a live sports punter 20 minute Mark then
double down cuz sirle has spoken and oh
no come
the
M but that is really good analysis and
and um I think the contrasting styles of
the two games that we've seen which are
really good leadup games to this final
obviously the mount smart one where all
blacks are able to play at super quick
speed they're playing on top of South
Africa and when they can do that they're
almost impossible to stop and if they
can get that again then I think all
black Victory is a no-brainer but in
contrast when South Africa can Mo set
piece um put all blacks under heaps of
pressure All Blacks discipline lets them
down then South Africa are going to be a
really hard team to beat as well like
you see in that scoreboard pressure
builds um very hard to try and catch up
to South and overtake them so like you
say all blacks need a big start and
speed of ball is going to be so
important and what we'll see from South
Africa a lot we've seen throughout the
whole world cup is any chance they can
they'll be looking to have an injury um
water break the water guys will be
coming on so how Wayne Barnes officiates
that he's going to be under a lot of
pressure and what he's going to do there
whether it's a real injury or is he's
going to just let it play on um because
we will see a lot of guys go down South
Africa will no doubt try and slow this
game down to as slow as possible so the
All Blacks will be trying to keep the
tempo I wouldn't be surprised if they'll
be looking at quick throws quick Taps
just to keep the pace because like you
said I feel like the All Blacks are a
lot fresher than South Africa they've
had huge minutes these um South Africans
in some big games and in the weekend
they did look a little bit tired can you
be tied in a World Cup final I'm not
sure never been in one but um yeah it's
going to be an interesting interesting
contrast of starles where do you say
snake I was just thinking that actually
you're last one Sur was talking about
the exits I wonder this week if the All
Blacks will go long kicks infield as in
not kick the ball out from their own 22
yeah keep it alive man I I love it when
teams basically back their Fitness
against the bigger team and just say
right we are not kicking the ball off
the park so whatever you got to do it
stays in field so whether that's long
and on and look they'll have to be bang
on with the kick Chase because we've
spoken about how dangerous South
Africa's back three are um in Broken
Field like those guys are no mugs but
South Africa's issue comes if that set
then gets to three minutes three minutes
30 four minutes ball in
play and the guys in the back three
haven't got the ball anymore that's when
they're going to have those long breaks
I think every time you're right every
time New Zealand kick the ball off the
Park South Africa will potentially bleed
45 seconds to a minute out of the game
walk back to the line out slow it down
as much as they can so definitely
somewhere where the All Blacks can get
par Surly man you talk so well about the
All Blacks you're convincing me
otherwise now making me second gu get up
how bad do you want that passport son
come on it's a thing I've learned you
just got to go down on your sword you
got to back the country and just go from
there n smart mate know your
audience I'm just I'm looking forward to
it for the for the same reason that I've
looked forward to a lot of games in this
competition maybe more so than in other
World Cups it's just just a contrast
it's going to be two massively different
styles um and I always think I I look I
love the all black Island game that was
obviously fantastic and there was some
ridiculous stuff but there's something
about one team trying to play quick
expansive heads up rugby keeping the
ball alive and the other team doing the
complete opposite and just seeing who
can get par in the game I think if the
All Blacks go out to a lead like I'm
kind of stealing to early's point now
but I don't think South Africa is set up
to chase a game so if the All Blacks at
any point go to scores up I don't see
where where do South Africa score two
tries from chasing a game out of nowhere
um but if South Africa get a lead I do
think the All Blacks can stay stay in
touch it's just it's it's such a close
matchup isn't it it's similar to what I
said before Ireland played um South
Africa in the group stages they're so
evenly matched but they're so different
it's so difficult to call ADS it's so I
guess one thing we haven't spoken about
is the weather as well obviously it
dictated the game with England and South
Africa in the weekend and four cast
suggests I think 60% is likely to be
rain so um odds are it's probably going
to be a little bit of rain around
obviously the All Blacks handled that
wet ball a lot better in the Argentina
game where I think the conditions were
obviously a lot worse than that other
semi-final but I do think rain will help
South Africa because it will suit their
slower game set piece to set piece and
there'll be a few more scrums
potentially from handling errors they'll
be going to the line out a lot more and
I think that will suit South Africa so
um I'm hoping for a nice dry evening
where we can play and see the best style
win but um shame they haven't got a roof
at the stadium cuz that would be ideal
um that would keep the atmosphere in too
so H but yeah I do think that's going to
play a part the
conditions who are we going for man of
the match boys start with you sirle man
of the match in the r Cup Final jeers
man there's there's probably two names
that that come to mine straight away and
that's Jordy Barrett and Ary s wow so
that's probably my back and my Ford
production but man without seeing the
team there's on that there's rumors that
white Lock's going to start have you and
they're going to go the Crusaders
locking Joo with Brody on the bench um
so that's that's some chat which I
thought is quite interesting because
I've love seeing white lock off the
bench just to kind of that cool head to
really bring it home old guzer has got a
bit more Mongrel about him eh so I
thought they might have started with him
but that that appears to be the chat
there so I wouldn't put it past the Sam
white loock as well who just loves the
game's biggest stage in the
arm and leg for it or just think our
most influential back I think we are a
completely different side when he's not
out there and then I think 's our most
inspirational forward in terms of he's
like a a leader that really vocalizes
his emotions and we get a lot of energy
off obviously Sam Kane's our Skipper and
he does an amazing job at it but I think
Ary leads in a different way where he
picks up a lot of the young boys and
stuff as well and and they kind of go
with him so those would probably be my
two picks at this stage two great shouts
and you're right like ad's got highlight
packages um plays in him throughout his
game man he's he works hard he he can do
it all he's he's an incredible player
and Jordy to go back to back that would
be a good sight to see but I believe Sam
wh loock is starting the only changes on
the bench um a reserve NPP and Coy at
Hooker so I don't think Coy is um oh
there we go but that's a that's an
interesting one it' be good to good for
these teams to name these um teams what
spoken about it's only fitting that we
still don't know the teams for the final
going into the last previous show of the
year so why change it and I'm interested
to see the South African side too
because what sort of split they go on
their bench that will obviously dictate
and whether the polard starts or they
stick with leok so a shame we can't talk
about that stuff but hopefully by the
next Rugby World Cup we will have the
teams announced a lot earlier so come on
World ragby um step up there who have
you gone snake who who would your man of
the match in this one be it's got to be
a South African because of course of
course I think it depends on what kind
of game it ends up being like you said
the weather is obviously gonna have a
massive massive Factor if it's really
bad conditions and it gets into that arm
wrestle game it's either going to be
polard or it's going to be one of the
South African front row I think
realistically um if someone has an
absolute field day at scrum time and
wins five straight arms then they they
might get man of the match or it might
be a classic paard kicks five goals and
everyone on TV picks him as the easy
pick in a in a boring game I I think if
if the LA if the the opposite happens
and it is an expansive open game then
I'd probably be changing my pick to
potentially the all backs and ay would
be the the obvious choice there for me
like like surle said and I think he's
one of those guys there's like three or
four different ways he could win man of
the match he could win man of the match
by scoring an unbelievable game-winning
try and having four five Harlot Real
Clips but he could also win man of the
match from making 27 tackles and putting
him the most meters around the park like
he's he's got everything in his in his
game and um I he's been absolutely
fantastic this world cup and uh he takes
the leadership box as well that I think
you need to win a a man of the match in
a World Cup final you need that
leadership Factor as well don't you to
to um to to to be able to lift that in
the World Cup final so those are those
are mine what do you reckon Tony I am
going to go Richie moang I feel like
nice he is just made for these big
Arenas he is incredible in the moments
and um I'm expecting a huge performance
from him and like you say if the All
Blacks are playing with quick ball um
High Tempo forwards are going forward
Richie manga is almost impossible to
stop he's just speed footwork decision
making skill level is incredible and
like like I said in a big stage like a
Rugby World Cup final there's not
another man who I think has that
composure to definitely um lead the boys
and get them across the line so I'm I'm
going him he's won the lad medal a
couple of times in Super Rugby finals
and now hopefully he can go the hatrick
with a Rugby World Cup man of the match
in a final he just on him like you know
him well so like obviously it was a
rough day for him off the tea but he's
so classy you expect that he can just
shake that off but what's he like does
he move on from stuff like that quickly
like will he be saying Jordy you kick
this week or does he want the tea
straight away I would imagine he would
be wanting the tea and he will be um
kicking his goals all this week so um
yeah I'd be pretty confident he'd be he
have no issues off the tea this weekend
and um even in saying that like if he is
hitting them poorly he wouldn't be
afraid to hand it over to Jordy as well
if Jord striking them really well in the
warm-up it's I guess advantage of having
a couple of world class kickers and
especially if Jordy has to take one from
long range and he strikes it really well
um really clutch man like Jordy isn't
phased by the moment ever so um yeah
couple of good options to have up this
sleeve but I'd imagine Richie will be
starting and that's a good point because
I need to select uh kicker for my
fantasy rookie team this weekend triple
kicker or whatever it is so um yeah it's
going to have to be Richie I'd imagine
so yeah nice there we go and I guess a
game no one's really speaking about um
the bronze medal match um probably for
good reason it's weird having a seventh
ranked team playing a fifth ranked team
for a third spot um would have been nice
for World rugby to just call in Ireland
and France and just say hey guys it's
clearly obvious you guys are the two um
two guys should the quarter finals get
that pre tournament they decided we coed
up the draw so the loser of these two
quarterfinals will play for third and
fourth if you lose your sem it would be
a much more interesting game I'm sure a
lot more people would tune into an
Ireland versus France game playing for a
bronze medal that would be intense but
um yeah I guess there's not a huge
amount of meaning people question
whether it should even be in in the draw
but obviously um it still sells out
usually still gets a lot of viewers it's
a money-making thing and um still
something to watch and good for fantasy
players as well because obviously the
game will probably be a bit more open
I'd imagine England are going to play a
bit of a looser style I see your mate
starting on the wing again snaky so it
looks like um England are going to look
to just throw the ball around a little
bit more and take the pressure off
hopefully not go straight into a
kickfest in a third and fourth playoff
no no no some really positive um
selections for England this week I think
I I like the whole back three they've
obviously gone Marcus back in on
fullback Henry on One Wing and then
Freddy Stewarts kept his spot in the
back three after an outstanding
performance in the week against South
Africa three young guys Marcus is the
oldest guy in that back three and he's
24 25 um so it's
definitely although that's a back three
I would be selecting FR England bwick
and Co are definitely looking at this as
a future building game as opposed to a
we need to win the bronze medal here
yeah um I mean you kind of alluded to it
before but I'll double down and it like
this game is so pointless lad
imagine imagine losing a World Cup
semi-final and then you've got a front
up for a test match six days later like
the lads have lost a World Cup
semi-final let them just go drown their
sorrows and bang Spates for a week like
rather than making them front up for
another test match but um yeah look
positive selections for me from England
looks like they're going to play um play
a little bit more special shout out from
my point of view to Ben Young's and
Courtney laws looks like it's going to
be their last unofficially I don't know
if it's been announced yet but looks
like it's going to be their last game
for England um two absolute Legends of
the game in this country man um Ben
Young's I think he's the most C player
for England of all time now and Courtney
Law's probably up there with Owen
Farrell in the most consistent High
performer for England I've seen in my
lifetime so two guys that have huge
amount of respect from from me and
everyone in the country they've been
fantastic players for a long long time
so it's nice that they get to to bow out
uh in a in a game rather than uh sort of
in a media message in the week um but um
in terms of selection I think England
get up in this game I think they've got
a better Squad they've had a better
tournament um but I I'm more interested
in just seeing the manner of the
performance in this game like I said the
result doesn't really matter I just want
to see if
england push the boat out there a little
bit more and see if we can grow our game
forward now they've obviously identified
that they needed to set up foundations
basic foundations of how they wanted to
play um my concern is that you know like
I said about the South Africa game
unless the the weather was bad we we're
not even in that game so um I want to
see more from them this week in terms of
how they push the game forward fair
enough England B plenty did you say
England B yeah 10 15 okay what are you
going
surely yeah I tend to agree it's going
to be interesting because I feel like
this game means more to Argentina than
it does to England like I feel like for
them to get third in a Rugby World Cup
like they would be absolutely fizzing
and straight away after that game
Michael Cho was like we're not done we
want to win bronze like this is what
we've come for so it's almost like they
knew they weren't going to beat the
or well you're on the podium how good so
look you got to find positives and
everything don't you apart from blaming
the ref that was pretty much all he said
so um uh it's going to be an interesting
one I'm to I'm excited to see this
English side play and it's cool that
like snaky said guys like courtne new
laws Legends of English rugby and guys
have been really fun to watch play footy
are going to go out on a high note like
I think the 2019 of course the All
Blacks were in it and I think we toed up
like Wales or something in a game that a
lot of people said they didn't watch but
I watched it because we were fear
Welling so many unreal like players from
our game so I think it's like a cool way
there's nothing worse than when you're
deciding you're going to hang up the
boots and you go out on a loss like even
though it's third or fourth You' rather
go out as a winner and and have a bit of
fun afterwards so yeah good on England I
think they'll win this one in that kind
of 10 to 15 Point range but it will be
interesting like if they don't rock up
with the same mindset Argentina could
well just beat them on passion but
England's the better footy side so we'll
see M I agree with everything you've
said depends what style and who who's
basically up for it more but England are
the better side um Argentina are lucky
to be there but um yeah a loose game of
footy um Carrera on the wing can have an
absolute field off there opening it up
so rug League predict better a rugby
league rugby league for sure another
thing that's come out this weekend is
obviously the Rugby World Cup format um
Keen to get your ideas obviously it's
going to be a shorter pool play more
teams um it obviously means more
coaching jobs for us um and it's
probably going to mean more blowouts no
real tough matches in the pools of any
significance until you get to the
playoffs but then a longer playoff
system so I quite like the idea I think
it's good to have a shorter pull um
system give ran a chance more teams
obviously grow the game a little bit
more so um I'm a fan of it what are you
guys thoughts what are your thoughts
stey yeah I think they expanded it to 24
to ensure the Wes will still qualify for
their home World Cup because you know
things were looking dicey there so I
think Eddie Jones has called in a couple
favors but no I like you I like it I
like I'm surprised they got the shorter
pool Play Over the Line with like player
welfare because obviously there's going
to be more games I missed those games
during the week man like this world cup
I feel like it was so spread out and
it's hard for players to back up on
short turnarounds but there was there
used to be nothing better than like a
Tuesday night just watching some code
like you that's when you would watch
these tier 2 Nations play each other
because you you were just craving some
footy and then you get to know a bit
more about their style of game so I'm
excited to see that back the biggest
thing for me was that the draw is going
to be done 18 months out not three years
out which is great stuff and still 18
months a lot can happen in 18 months so
even then it's probably a bit far but
like compared to what we've been dished
up lately it seems really close so
hopefully that kind of nullifies that
quarterfinal situation we had this year
I'm worried about this top 16 because I
saw someone did like a prediction on who
it would be based off the tournament
this year and there's some there's some
80 plus pointers in there which isn't
really the idea of finals footy but yeah
look I'm all for it I think if we're
going to become a global game then 24 is
probably the right number and hopefully
sides like Portugal and that just
continue to improve and they could Rock
up and make that round of 16 like with
some upsets yeah that's interesting and
you mentioned like um the player wal I'm
pretty sure because there's only four
teams in each pool you'll only have the
three games so I think I think it will
be just one one game a week six PS of
four six PS of four so I was thinking
four Ps of six and it was going to be
brutal nah nah nah four pools of six
pools of four so they're all pretty
small pools it's pretty clear who the
top guys of each pool are going to be my
dyslexia got the better of me sorry boys
sort around the wrong way sh do you have
anything to add on that one snake or you
want to get straight into the world
challenge no I think um look I think
first and foremost it's positive that
they're trying to do something I think
it's pretty obvious that somewhere there
needs to be some kind of change to the
global structure to try and make the
more globalized you know obviously the
Rugby's fantastic in a set amount of
countries and we love watching those
countries play against each other but if
we're thinking about the sport thriving
and developing and having new domestic
leagues form and growing across the
whole globe then the only way to do that
is to try and open it up to more of
these teams and have a World Cup that is
closer to the football World Cup where
you've got teams from all over the world
coming everyone on all over the planet
is watching and and very very quickly
that then becomes a you know a catalyst
for grow both of rugby in different
countries um I like most of the changes
that they've made to the structure of
the World Cup I I would be Keen for what
Sly said to condense the whole
tournament have midweek games and let
the the squads carry bigger squads I
understand there's an issue there with
depth in terms of some of the minow
teams they wouldn't have good enough
depth to run a 40 plus player Squad but
man I'd love to see the All Blacks take
you know the All Blacks and the other
bigger sides take 45 guys to a World Cup
and have to run two games a week having
a a first string team and a second
string team especially a pool play and
just churn the tournament through
quickly so that you get like World Cup
fever because I feel like one of the
things this world cup struggled with is
like the weekends have been awesome but
then just down in the week it kind of
dials off doesn't it and then it's hard
the weekend games again and then DARS
offw is I think what's great about the
football World Cup for example is you
just have a block where it's hectic and
every day like when you're a kid you
come home from school rug the game's on
the game's on who's on when you're an
adult it's who's in your multi this week
getting your tfold multi and just games
every day for a shorter period for me is
better than games on the weekend for a
really long period then it just kind of
Fizzles out I I do have issues with the
the um the Nations League thing that
we're going to talk about next I mean
Jim if you want to go first just on that
last point I do think they could
potentially do that when you've got six
pools obviously you're only playing the
team in your pool you could almost have
one each day so you know pool a play on
the Tuesday pool and then you can still
do FY rugby as well as long as all the
teams named because that's that's the
disappointing side of the midweek game
it's very hard to structure a fantasy um
fantasy league around it and that is you
know the priority for a lot of people
these days um I know yours is the multi
but for some of us non-gamblers it is
all about fantasy rugby so but we will
get to why not both or both yeah um but
we will get to the world challenge um
that one's obviously been announced I
think it's an awesome idea I just think
they've missed
they've just missed a trip with it I
just feel like there needed to be some
sort of similar competition underneath
it and a definite promotion relegation
where teams like samai who easy to
forget almost beat England a couple of
weeks ago um who are now playing for a
third place in a Rugby World Cup SAR are
definitely competitive enough to be in
the in these sort of tournaments and
they need to be to help help them grow
so we've definitely missed a trick there
and give not given these um some of
these tear two Nations at opportunity to
compete but um I do like I do like it I
do like parts of it so interest to get
your thoughts so what do you got snake
you always you love the stuff and you're
Hammer my yeah and I'm Hammer my issue
is the two different proposed things
don't marry up with each other so you've
introduced a World Cup which is
brilliant more teams introducing more
countries bigger competition but then
you're not letting those teams play
against the top teams in the leadup to
the World Cup so you're going to have a
situation where more teams in a
tournament aren't at the level of the
teams that are already set in the
tournament and we don't want to see 80
90 point blowouts and I feel like what
they've inherently set up here is a
league one where everyone's going to get
better and better and better and then
they're gonna how many teams is in the
top League 12 16 12 10 10 I think it's
10 yeah so you're gonna have 10 teams in
this top League who are going to play
against each other play in this super
competitive super league and then
they're going to get stuck in a world
cup with four 14 other teams who have
just been left defend for themselves and
I think again it's a good idea to try
and connect the global game and as much
as we love the history I do think it
that we need to try and find a way away
from Six Nations rugby championships
those things can still exist but maybe
not on an annual thing maybe they're a a
by annual thing or every two years and
um but there needs to be some kind of
connection between those 10 teams in
this Super League comp and then
everybody else behind who's going to
ultimately have to play in a Rugby World
Cup and whether
that's whether look I don't know I don't
have the answers but whether they could
have structured it to have a league with
two pools and then go into a top group
and a second group based on some games
in and run as a two-year thing or or
whether like you said promotion and
relegation is a cool idea imagine seeing
two countries play off to try and get
into the top league in a in a you know
having a playoffs to try and get into
the top league and then there's also
consequence you know if Italy turn up
and do what they did meet at this world
cup then they get binned down they have
to think about what they did for a year
um I just yeah I just for me the two
ideas don't does that am I articulating
it well like super well mate you need a
drink more you're on fire what about you
Sly no basic I I basically agree I was
thinking like maybe they run it like the
sevens you know how they have like the
tournaments on but then there's also the
second tier tournaments at the same time
like they they need two tiers they need
the promotion relegation I see they've
said 2030 they're bringing that in but
why does that take 6 years to come into
play like I feel like World rugby has
kind of scratched the surface here
they've announced this tournament and
the build up to the biggest weekend on
their calendar for the next four years
and kind of been like how cool is this
but hoped it would get swept under the
rug because everyone's got World Cup
fever whereas then guys like liop wer
and stuff hits off to them they've just
seen it straight away and starting to
speak up about it like it's unreal for
Fiji they're probably the biggest
beneficiary from all of this but besides
like s and that they've just been left
in the Lurch and it was the perfect
opportunity for World rugby to unleash
this unreal like setup where your
portugals and stuff are all playing each
other all these teams that won the
hearts from World Cups but they kind of
dropped the ball on it a bit so it's a
bit disappointing I'd love to see a
promotion relegation game straight away
it makes every test match you play
throughout the year so much more
important too CU you don't want to get
relegated so you're not just going to to
send your bside over to play some of
these tier 2 teams cuz I don't know it's
done on points or whatever and you got
to be in the top 10 for that year to
make it and then there's a second tier
like I think they could have done it so
much better but for the top Nations it's
really good right we get to see Ireland
France we place up Africa so much more
so the strong are going to get stronger
and the fear is that the weak are going
to get weaker which is and then those
teams that are in the Middle Ground kind
of get sucked down to wherever level
they're playing at so for some Nations
you're for some Nations you're
heartbroken like Tonga and S Mo on paper
have some of the most exciting squads
but this is going to hurt them massively
right like imagine if they were in this
competition now you'd see so many more
Top Class players be like I want to play
in that improve my point and now it's
almost like I don't know devaluing them
it's a bit but I don't know there's
pros and cons to everything and yeah I
just wish they kind of like snaky said
if they want to be a global game you
you've got to invest in these smaller
like rugby playing Nations or else the
Gap is never going to get smaller and
they keep saying that's the goal is to
get a smaller Gap and then they do
something like this after announcing
that they're adding four more teams it's
like man what the hell it doesn't quite
add up and it does look from the outside
to be very driven by money you've
obviously got um you know they've got to
make a business out of it as well so
that but like yourself if they're going
to say that they're going to invest into
the game being you know a global game
and try and build up these other teams
then they have to invest in it and
looking at this competition they're not
they're looking at making more money but
maybe with that money they're going to
invest heaps of it into um the L Nation
so I don't we never quite know what's
going on behind the scenes but you two
saving Rugby World Problems by yourself
yeah I I think we've got a gig lined up
snaky mate we got a gig and I'll just
leave with a parting shot on Eddie Jones
he's lucky mate he's lucky to be in
there they're lucky they're in the rugby
Championship Je
oh anyway L we've got one more review to
re review next week the final I'm
looking forward to that one but as
always some of the best analysis you
will get right here on waterair dance
with France um podcast so appreciate
your time as always thanks for staying
up so late snake um after a night out
gez you've done well appreciate it
anything for you Lads up the ABS Jimmy
mate I reckon we return the favor next
week and just send it early doors get on
s level yeah up the a 13 plus boys get a
monster